you support a ban on the feel-good you
what if I told you I'm a Muslim American
hopefully you now violent person we're
in Cleveland Ohio for day one of the
Republican National Convention and the
theme today is make America safe again
so what does that mean for all of these
pump supporters should we ban Muslims
from entering New York fortunately I say
yes everyone so I should get a real
leave the country or convert maybe the
Christianity I believe that that one
wants to build a wall do you support
that
that's what this rhetoric for the wall
explain drops per day they built the
wall you're part of the brigade well we
look I'll be there that day that wall
starts you think Muslims should be
banned from entering the country I think
for right now I'm a Muslim American and
my parents are immigrants that came here
well you already do American give a hand
that we're falls off
give a hand does that mean that you guys
are on the news well no we're armed with
patriotism and courage